maybe we want to let you know that the
final rhett and Link musical show dates
of the year and for the foreseeable
future are right coming up on us so
November 20th through November 23rd
we're gonna be in Albuquerque New Mexico
Phoenix Arizona Sacramento California
and Valley Center California go to rhett
and Link live.com to grab those tickets
we promise we will make it a very very
special night worth your time rhett and
Link live.com
go get em tix now on with the biscuit
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
exploring the challenges of maintaining
a friendship we're not gonna necessarily
talk about I mean I'm sure we will we're
not talking about the challenges in our
friendship maybe you know maybe some of
them will come out as we talk about the
challenges and your friendships that you
have led us into thank you for those of
you who have responded to our props on
the social medias that we have asked and
told us about some of your situations
that you've got with your friends yeah
everyone to address if we've got
anything it's good here it's a
friendship no it's a friendship
friendship yeah it's it's a friendship
and you know with over 35 years of that
continuing to happen like Kant's
friendship is still happening if you
know it's despite the doubts in the
comments from time to time right I and I
would say you know it to be friends as
long as we have and to not get like
concerned comments from fans who are
only seeing us through the lens of the
lens would be that would be weird I mean
for for us not to be comfortable enough
with each other that sometimes these
honest moments of tension come through
and the things we create I think that's
a beautiful thing because it's again
it's those every everything in
friendship is not rosy friendship in
general is very difficult and as
look through these questions that that
that we're going to discuss from
mythical beasts it's a good reminder of
to me about how much work it takes you
know I don't want to show our hand here
but it does it does take a lot of work
and it's and there's no clear answers
because on any given day in any given
friendship there could be any scenario
that you've never experienced before and
you may not know anyone who's been
through it so you kind of like what do I
do
so we'll talk about some of that yeah
and like all relationships they have
their projects that have to receive
attention and so hopefully we can offer
some insights but you know speaking of
our friendship viewing friendship as of
your friend is a project it's maybe a
bad place to start well you know what I
mean it's ongoing attention but a person
is not a project that's not what I meant
but speaking of friendship and
maintaining friendships I mean we did
something that is just about as friendly
as you could possibly do we went and
went on paddle boats this password yeah
yeah I mean right went out on a paddle
boat together can you picture this two
of us on at Echo Park there's a lake
which I guess is called Echo Lake is it
I just call it Echo Park Lake I don't
know if that code it you know
but Echo Park Lake it's like the most
one of the most LA things that you can
do is get on Echo Lake Echo Park Lake
Echo Park is get on one of these giant
swans that is a paddle boat that can
hold like five people and paddle around
this pond and I've been by this place so
many times in a minute me too gotta get
out on one of those paddleboats you'll
see it in like if a if a commercial
decides to shoot in Los Angeles
especially if they need like a
picturesque scene like if it's a if it's
an ad for a medication they'll shoot at
Echo Park now they'll though they'll
film at such an angle where like you can
from from one side of the lake shoot
across these fountains there's three
fountains that are grouped together that
shoot water probably fifty feet in the
air straight up in the air and then you
shoot past that and you can see the
skyline of downtown Los Angeles it's
very beautiful you just got to make sure
that you that you do you film the proper
angle around the homeless encampments
there are a few of those right but
they're very well probably get them to
leave when they're good about a shoot of
commercial they're very well maintained
homeless camps because I mean they're
like there's a camp under this tree and
then you go to the next stream there's a
camp but I mean they got nice tits and
there's this one guy here to frigging
where we parked he had a flat screen
television beside his tent and I was
like how on earth and then before I
could get my answer I was like oh solar
panel yeah a solar-powered dude had
solar panel that screen TV out there and
a nice tent and so it was like this is
prime real estate
I made an I made a note right if if I
need to lit up and live out of a tent
ula is a great place well you got to get
a flat-screen and a solar panel I'm
already here
and there's just so much going on I mean
the thing about any outdoor space in Los
Angeles on the weekend really anytime
but especially the weekend is there's
just so much happening there's so many
people there and I know for a lot of
people that can be a problem because
you're like why can't I just go to an
open space now you can easily get to
open spaces where you won't see a soul
you decide to go outside of town but it
was just like so many people of all
walks of life almost as if the the the
the people had been manufactured for the
sake of a movie or foreign insurance
commercial ah I mean around medication I
mean you got people selling things you
got this guy giving free vegan ice cream
samples next to a guy selling ceviche
Vijay and then you got the taco place
and it's just I don't even know if these
people have licenses or permits I don't
even care and then so picture me and
Rhett holding hands and skipping around
this lake together hopping on
a swan and just peddling out there with
our with our gene cutoff shorts yeah if
you want a thighs I'm sorry to
disappoint you but we actually didn't
get on the same Swan my sister-in-law
and two nieces were in town and then I
you're I think your wife had the idea to
be like hey let's let's all go to the
swans let's all get on the paddle boats
let's do this thing that we've talked
about doing for 10 years and we've never
done so it was you and your wife and two
of your kids no one of your kids no me
and Christy were on a pedal boat and
they call him no I would say not paddle
I'm just saying who was there at the
this event the my wife what we can do it
my son
so me and Christy were on a boat got and
just you and Christy just me and Kristin
oh how you worked that out because you
volunteered to place the younger the
kids so Shepherd and his first cousin
Adeline my brother's daughter is like
there they are each other's favorite
people they're the same age same age
within like a couple months and they
just love each other they love spending
time with each other they're into all
the same things and they just you know
two peas in a pod as you say in the
south and they really love to include
Lando which is very cool he's you know
he and Shepherd are really tight but
Lana's a little bit younger so I think
it's nice when Adeline enters the
equation that they still want to include
him and invite him over to swim and
stuff like that and by the way you do
know that Shepherd jumps off of the roof
of the the shed that covers the back
half of your patio into the pool yeah
they recently discovered they could do
that well they invited Lando over and
then Lando comes we're drug we pick him
up and he's coming back home and you
know how Lando is he like had this
sheepish look on his face and I
remembered I was like did you Lando did
you jump off of the the roof into the
pool he was like yeah a Shepherd
Shepherd told me I should do it Oh Lando
did it and he did it that's awesome and
then he started crying he was like don't
be mad at me I was like we're not
boy I Shepard has never cried about
anything except not getting his way
definitely never cried about getting
caught for something so the three of it
so three of them wanted to be in the
same boat and then you stepped up to the
plate
I knew it an adult had I liked being the
fun uncle you know the funcle' and I'm
quite a funcle' and I was like I'm gonna
go out with these kids they'll be fun we
can drive through I knew we won they
would want me to drive really close
drive I think paddle if you drive a boat
you do drive a boat because there is a
Strutter they wanted me to go really
close to the giant fountains because the
wind is like blowing the water that's
going fifty feet in the air and of
course you can go right under it and get
wet and it's like going on the log ride
at Disney Chrissie and I watched you do
that from a safe distance yeah we spent
most of our time trying to get an
Instagram bubble photo you know how that
is
did you get one uh yes you know what she
did grab one so I think she got what she
needed I always forget that that's a
thing that you can do I think it's just
a sign of my age that social media is
still just not a part of my DNA I'm
doing things that oh kissed on the right
thing man that was good I know but you
mean this is what we do man it's like
you if you're in a dream about it if
you're in a giant Swan you should get a
picture of yourself in a giant one
there's a freaking coffee shop out there
I got a lavender you make it sound like
it's in the middle of the lake
doc you have to walk through a little
coffee shop that serves breakfast
burritos on the weekends what yeah I
love it
I got a lavender latte and I'm not
ashamed of that I love when lavender is
in things it's one of my favorite
flavors to be in things something that
seems like it shouldn't be ingested yeah
let's eat perfume that that sounds like
a good lavender latte made me so happy
it's just almost as happy as being in a
swan on a lake
chasing swans did you notice that you
could chase other swans with this giant
Swan do you think that the little swans
believe that the giant swans are swans
no you think they know they're inanimate
you think they have a concept of
inanimate sea is that a word I think
they
they're not of their kind I don't think
there's I don't think they look at that
thing and register that it is trying to
impersonate them in any way did you know
that you did these swans on the weekends
you can go out there until ten o'clock
and you saw the light the light yet I
got some led piping piping on it you can
you could think about that you could go
out there and night we could be like the
Tourism Board for Echo Park if we don't
watch out and then we paddled to the far
end and by the way this was the other
the other boat was Jessie and your
sister-in-law Teresa and then my other
niece Lily and then your older niece
who's closer in age to Lily
yeah Emery mm-hmm which they were
hanging out so it's really cool it was
you know Christmas we it there's he had
a lot of good ideas we'll get to the
second one and then she
so we powder all the way across we're
like trying to keep up with you and the
kids which they got mad because you
wouldn't let them peddle
no no what's the story no no they kept
switching off so I would be on one side
I was on the left side I know so only
two people can pedal yeah at a time so I
was like I'm gonna pedal because I don't
want to be in the back and have to deal
with two little kids up front trying to
direct what we're girls it's hard to be
funcle' and so you're not I'd rather see
let them rotate in the other seat but
then eventually they were mad they
wanted me to be in the back and they
wanted to be driving it and so I
eventually I was gonna let them do that
but what's the first thing that you
noticed when you got out there it's
really hard to paddle yeah you don't go
anywhere I was like this is this is my
workout for the day oh man I felt the
burn yeah like really I felt the burn
and then I felt the burn when I went to
the gym whoa I was my trainer was like
okay we're gonna do squats and I'm doing
squats my back is if my back is back man
and now I'm doing squats saying it I
mean we'll see how long it lasts not a
lot of hit not a lot of weight though
but I was like man I was like having
trouble I was like well I did
paddleboats this week yeah that's like I
was the only person to say that in the
gym that morning a paddleboat it too
hard this weekend well you went outside
and there's a group of people on the
bank yeah and you got there before we
did
you just sat in you're looking at I'm
gonna pull up and it's a freaking
freestyle rap session battle rap battle
it's a rap battle on the far end of reco
part I love this town like where can you
go get a lavender latte get on a giant
slide and then paddle your way to a rap
battle I mean nowhere
people always ask me every time I go
back home to North Carolina they're like
do you like it out there with so much
skepticism dripping in their voice I
love it and then you know what you got
the level of Lottie I went out to use
the bathroom and there was a homeless
man with his ass in the sink I love it
here he was washing his ass that's a
good enough place to start I didn't I
didn't want you to go gawk at him I
wanted a man to have his privacy the Sun
was setting it was golden our uh man I
mean for a man who takes a shower and
stares his neighbor's down I I respected
this guy anything his dominance yeah and
then your wife had a great idea we were
trying to figure out what we were gonna
eat and she said well we can go get some
deep-dish pizza and I was like say no
more we were on the lake and then you
started peddling for the shore before
she even told me where it was
I haven't had deep dish pizza in so long
and there's this place is that in
Highland Park where that place is a corn
masa Echo Park I don't know why it's
called masa that makes it sound like it
might be an Indian restaurant but it is
it is straight up
chicago-style deep dish takes an hour
for them to bake a pie it's very
reminiscent of Lou Malnati's in Chicago
because we got the original they call it
which is sausage and mushroom and it's
got that corn bread crust stuff that's
like the crispy very cornmeal II crust
and the sausage is a giant piece of
sausage that's the same size as the
pizza which I've only ever seen that at
luminaries which I'm sure that's done
other places but like yeah we we got
pizza and Chrissy was like you can only
eat about one piece of this stuff oh
yeah it's so huge so and I would I could
finally got there and I got to the crust
of the first piece and I'm like I start
to think man I I it tastes so good I
want another piece but I don't think I
can do it and I looked over and you had
you were at the crust as well and I
thought for a second we were on pace
until you said that's my third piece
[Music]
it's crazy you were going exceptionally
slow though it's so dense it's so good I
had three pieces and then you you ate
and you ain't like the dense it's like
eating the dense loaf of bread like
eating the whole loaf yeah and then I
told you then I'll say again I could
have had a fourth piece the only reason
I didn't is because y'all made me feel
bad about having three but D you know to
transition back these are the things
that friendships are made of friendships
are made of good times Rap Battles an
deep dish pizza and bad times and LED
light piping you know you you can't
really really quantify a friendship
until you go through some bad times
together and I even say plural it's
basically going through life together so
as we go through these questions I think
I think we'll get very specific about
some problems that pop up and even how
to maintain or reconnect in a friendship
things that things that we've been
through we are no we are no experts but
we'll do our best but first we want to
let you know that mythical calm
continues to be the place to go for all
your mythical needs and we've got this
call it the hub of happiness that yeah
we've got what we're calling the
transcendental tea we're doing so we're
just experimenting
we're introducing new stuff all the time
back in Allen
the back of it is a big version of the
front that is nice it says mythical in a
lot of ways it's a little spooky it
might be it might be a kind of
Illuminati oh I got to tell you I got it
you say Lou Malnati's speaking about
pizza I was literally at something
recently that I have to tell you about
and somebody brought up on ironically
Bohemian Grove both Bohemian Grove oh
yeah yeah oh yeah you gonna tell me
about it I'll tell you about it now
that's a secret man because I want to
get him fight it man oh go to mythical
dot-com the hub of happiness because
clothes make you happy getting a new
something that you can wear bless the
message it's a little slice of happiness
you want to be happy go to the hub of
happiness mythical calm and we're back
on the flip side of our ads you want to
get started with a question do it this
is from kosugi which is Casa Nora on
Twitter who she's changed her name to
cappucci it's a little dated after
Halloween so yeah well she answered this
question before Halloween so she it was
called a spooky at the time I have a
friend that chronically cancels
last-minute will plan dinner or a
hangout I'll be halfway through cooking
the meal or heading to her place when
she texts me to say that she can't meet
anymore less than one hour notice she
always seems so excited up until she
cancels sad emoji yeah this is this is
extremely frustrating Christie Christie
had a friend who was like this a chronic
cancel a chronic canceller back in the
day and so I would hear about it she
would complain to me and I we wanted to
make sure that there wasn't some
unspoken thing going on it's like do you
just feel obligated to make plans but
you don't you're not really motivated to
follow through so you're looking for an
excuse and and the conclusion in this
particular
example was no that wasn't the case
she's there's there's some people who
just they can't they can't keep plans
together but I would say it has to be on
the table to consider is this is this an
avoidance thing but let's assume it's
not because because like she said she's
very excited always so excited up until
she cancels and she's probably
apologetic or he's probably apologetic
or whatever so it feels like it has to
be addressed right so I think honest
communication about the elephant in the
room which is you're always canceling on
me needs to be specifically addressed
and I think that you could no longer
wonder is it about is this is this an
avoidance thing is this because you
could just say hey there seems to be a
pattern where we've got plans and then
you cancel them at the last minute and I
just want to know and I want you to be
honest with me is this something that's
just related to this the way that you
schedule your stuff and it's just
unfortunate circumstance or is it that
you just don't want to hang out because
I just I feel like I need to know as
your friend yeah that's a tough that's a
very tough thing to say but I do feel
like you got it if you want to actually
make progress in this area like you want
to pursue this friendship you got to
take that head-on right I think a
through-line of everything we're going
to talk about it is talked about is
gonna be how key communication is I mean
when you're when you're left guessing
you never know if you're right but I I
think that I I'll end up sharing a story
where I did choose to communicate
something and it went sideways so
communication alone is not the key it
has to be proper you know I think and I
don't know all the criteria but I think
it's this if you if you try to have as
much humility as possible so it's not a
confrontation but like I like the way
you said it that was like a humble
approach it's like hey this is I just
want to share how this makes me feel
I actually don't know what to conclude I
really would like to hear from you about
this because be very careful when
jumping to conclusions preemptively
especially if it makes you upset
aggressive something like that and that
even me talking like that I started to
get I start to wig out when it feels
like we're just giving advice it's like
I I don't like being those people so I
just I like to share more about just
what we would do but I do think that in
this instance you you never know what
the other person is going through or if
they're just they may just be oblivious
to what they're doing and the impact
that it has has on you hey I made dinner
we I mean we made plans I I sacrifice
doing other things to make sure that we
had this time because that's what plans
do plans mean you're not planning to do
everything else and I would say that the
vast majority of the time assuming that
what is going on is this person is just
a little bit flighty you communicating
that this is a concern of yours and
pointing it out will I don't know I'm
not especially scheduled scheduled or in
person but I'm I'm not very flighty
either like I'm if I say I'm gonna be
somewhere I'm gonna be there but my
assumption is that people who are kind
of like scattered is that all it takes
what you're constantly doing what
somebody's got that personality is
you're kind of competing for they're
sort of unofficial floating priorities
yeah and so by simply expressing concern
about something you move yourself to the
top of and so the next time you say
you've got plans they will be like okay
I know that I have a tendency to kind of
flake out so I don't want to do that
because because Casa Nora said that this
was an issue and so I'm going to honor
that I have it I think that's probably
what's gonna happen now if you don't if
you can't make that if you can't
communicate in that way if you're a
person who just avoids
conflict at all costs then I think that
you got to make Plan B's I think you got
to have a back-up plan that you're okay
you're not emotionally drained by having
to go to plan B so you'll be like all
right
I got plans with you-know-who which
means it might fall through but if it
doesn't happen I'm gonna eat a whole
deep-dish pizza and watch ghostbusters
you know you got yeah you gotta have
something that you can look forward to
so that you don't get pissed at them
yeah but you can kind of reward yourself
and almost kind of hope they cancel well
yeah I definitely agree that you got to
find a way to not harbor resentment
towards this person because it's not
going to change overnight you know the
type of person that does this is going
to keep struggling with it even even if
you having a great conversation it may
take two or three times but it's gonna
it's gonna happen again so you have to
find a way and maybe that's you you
invite them to things where there's
other people so the plans aren't
contingent on that person flaking or not
not flaking you know yeah so it's like
the thing can continue and hey you're
invited if you want to come but I've
changed the way I look I know you do
things yeah let's move to it let's move
to another one I know that there was the
one that it's like three different so
three different people basically asked a
very similar question so I will quickly
read all these first ones from post card
HS how do you reconnect with someone
that you used to be best friends with I
had a best friend but ever ever since we
went to different schools we stopped
talking second question from Cameron if
you haven't talked to someone for a
while and nothing really ended your
friendship like a fight or moving away
etc are you still friends with that
person should you reach out and have a
conversation or should you just let it
go and Lanie how do I reconnect with a
friend that I haven't hung out with
regularly since elementary school I have
close neighborhood friends s that
stopped hanging out with me when our
mutual friend died should I move on or
try to befriend them again and if so how
hmm it's interesting because you know
we've gone through life together so
we've always had each other but we've
also made really good friends over the
years that I do I wonder if you would
call it a pattern of like losing losing
connection you know it's everybody that
we've connected with and you know it's
like you had the grit we got the grade
school through high school friends had
some tight friendships there then we had
some really tight college friends and
then we had there's there's like a few
post college people and like I'm
thinking of specific people all along
the way that when we especially when we
moved out here our friendship got more
more insolent well we made friends out
here you know but all those friends were
physically left behind but then we would
I think it's a continuing pattern of
like not really maintaining those
friendships and we discussed on a
previous podcast about our issues with
texting and in talking on the phone
mm-hm and neither of us are good at
either of those and we don't use texting
or talking on the phone really as a way
to connect with people it's usually a
way to coordinate some particular
strategic action and then you couple
that with the fact that everybody's busy
I understand but we our time is very
much scheduled like we've got friends
there's a lot of people that we're
friends with in Los Angeles and you'll
be on a text thread with them and it'll
be like 2:30 p.m. on a Wednesday and all
of a sudden they start texting each
other and they text each other and
they're like putting memes in there and
they're telling somebody's telling a
story and somebody's responding to it
right 2:30 p.m. on a Wednesday 95 times
out of a hundred we're doing something
that we just can't I can't just be like
I'm gonna get out of this meeting or
this brainstorming session or whatever
it is and enter into this text chat so
we don't for all intents and purposes
before our working hours we're
unavailable we don't have a it's like we
don't have a phone for personal use and
then when we get home
okay I haven't seen my kids or my wife
all day I'm gonna spend some quality
time with them maybe I'll be able to
stay up long enough to watch a
television show with my wife if I can do
it but I'm going to bed pretty early so
I can get up and go to the gym it's like
we don't leave a lot of space and for
connecting with people who are not close
to us physically it's got to be like
okay all right we're going out with this
couple on a double date on Friday night
or we're having this is it how six weeks
from now and you know it's like a lot of
it has to be booked because then you've
got you got a couple of nights on the
weekend you got you got the stuff that
your kids have planned that you got to
attend and you got like okay you got
relatives coming into town like your
yeah like your nieces so so now that we
can have a difficult time just keeping
up with the people in Los Angeles and
then you've got people who live in
different parts of Los Angeles and if
they're on the west side that might as
well be in South Carolina you know and
so then everybody back home in North
Carolina people that you've been friends
with for a long time unless you're
someone who can text and talk on the
phone for extended period of time those
friendships become like we've got a
number of friendships where I consider
myself very close to someone that is in
North Carolina and if we decide to come
to get together while I'm in North
Carolina or they come out here we have a
great time and we pick up exactly where
we left off and I think we've all kind
of accepted this isn't the kind of
friendship that we're going to be like
relying on each other on a regular basis
this is a this is something we re-enter
into right like two examples so Mike
from from back in North Carolina work
will bring him out here to California
and sometimes it may not be too close
and maybe like Bakersfield but then
he'll make a point and we're like with a
lot of advance notice to like initiate
with us and say hey I'm coming into town
can we get together one night or let's
go camping for a few nights you know we
used to do that like once a year we
would go camping it was something that
like he would always initiate it you
know because he was the one coming into
town he would give his heads up and we
would so we always make some time
lately over the past couple years we
haven't been able to make the time for
the camping like we used to do but it's
but it's on his initiative whenever
whenever I go back to North Carolina the
timing is so limited I'm just
prioritizing my family and if I get to
see one friend when I'm there I'm very
lucky because it's like the once a year
trip and then you've got the the other
another example like Eric who lives in
Utah and so when we go to he lives in
Park City so when we would go to
Sundance well I mean if he found out we
were going there we didn't see him that
would be that would be an insult I mean
it's like because I mean he's a high
school friend he was in the wax paper
dogs with us we don't we don't really
communicate at all except when we happen
to see him there or like when we went we
went to something else oh and we had a
show we introduced him to the audience
in Utah in Salt Lake yeah and salt like
Salt Lake City and so but when we see
him or when we see Mike it's like the
friendship picks up right where it left
off and I think those are two examples
of like an understanding I think that in
a lot of ways those individuals like
Mike or Eric have I feel like they've
kind of adjusted to us in some way but
yeah that's my assumption I know Mike
because I've been friends with him for a
long time is the kind of guy who will
get on the phone and talk for a long
time like he his job requires him to
drive a lot of places and he'll talk to
people on the phone and he can't he can
eat but he doesn't talk to you right you
don't talk to him no very rarely it's
like we'll text and we'll get something
set up and then of course then we have
like long conversations the three of us
once we're doing something like camping
together or whatever right but and like
we got the friend who he went back to
Australia for like weeks yeah and it's
like we're really tight but it's like I
find that the conversations that we have
over text it's more like when you coming
back
mm-hmm it's not like let's continue our
friendship while you're gone but this
because I'm just so bad
continuing a friendship over text you
know so I find that it's like it's all
just very practical and I think we've
talked about that before and like
learning how there is an opportunity for
text to be a legitimate way to continue
a friendship but I I have this I have
this sense of guilt and obligation
whenever like I fall out of connection
with somebody and I think I just put
that on myself and over the years I feel
like when the two of us talk about it
we've said things that have made me feel
better that I don't know if they're true
or healthy but we say things like well
you know I'm not good at text I'm not
good at long-term friendships but if
when I see him it would be fine you know
but like like a great example is Greg we
were super tight with Greg in college
and like you know he's he's working he's
working up in Washington State and doing
his own thing and like I we saw him we
went on tour up there like they came in
but it's not like occasionally he'll
text me and then we'll have an exchange
that all it'll fizzle out over the
course of ten minutes and then in the
past there would it be like let's have
we would hop on the phone a couple of
times we'd have like an hour-long
catch-up session but like I mean I love
my mama but I have a really hard time
calling her on the phone and
reconnecting mm-hm this sense of guilt
that's like I don't talk to my mom
enough or like I don't like I wish that
I had a more of an active friendship
with Greg because he's so busy with his
work much like us it's like he doesn't
have the opportunity to come down here
and visit and we don't have the
opportunity to go up there and visit and
you know so it's that's a that's been
difficult because I you know I actually
I've moved from feeling I don't know I
moved from feeling like this is just the
way it is I still love the guy and I
know he loves me but the circumstances
make it work our friendship can't be
active to feeling bad about it
and it kind of back-and-forth I don't
know yeah I just I don't like I don't
want to put that on myself you know what
I'm saying like I don't I know I can
make all kinds of excuses but I just
don't want to I don't think it's healthy
for me personally to Phil to sit around
and feel guilty about about it yeah yeah
now it's it's one thing if the person is
going through something specifically
challenging and they need me yeah
if they don't and none of the people
that I'm thinking about right now don't
have some that some people in their
lives that can meet some of those needs
do you know I'm not enough I'm not in a
place to be like what what can I do for
you tangibly mm-hmm and so I have just
kind of become okay with the nature of
these friendships is that they pick up
where they left off when they do and
that's a great thing and there's no hard
feelings and I just feel like trying to
make anything more of it I don't know
they just I I just feel like I'm setting
myself up for disappointment
both disappointment of myself and
disappointed them being disappointed in
me if I like start trying to say hey
actually the the dynamic of this thing
is going to change like we're going to
have this dynamic long-distance
friendship via text or via phone call
every now and again I just know that
it's not gonna be a reliable thing and I
just don't want it's not really in it
for you and yeah I think it'll become
more clear that I do have some neurosis
associated with this but you know
there's a I I would like to believe to
build on your point that if if we heard
that Gregg or someone in his family was
going through something that if we knew
we could be of help by being
that we would we would do everything we
can to drop what we're doing to go up
there you know if it if it if there was
something bad that happened if they were
going through something but in the
absence of that you know and it an
occasional text it's like hey you
crossed my mind
you know is is I still aspire to to like
to at least dabble in that yeah and it's
interesting because you know we were
closest with Greg and then in college
and then Tim moved in and then like Tim
was really close with Matt and we got
close to Matt and you know we got a text
from Matt yesterday and all he was doing
was asking about if we had listened to
an album you know did you get that text
because I did and I listened to the
album but you responded on the text
thread and then I never got around to
responding on the text thread which is
an interesting thing that happens
sometimes
where if somebody is sending something
to the both of us whether it's an email
or a text I've got this thing in my mind
that if one of us responds the other one
isn't obligated to it I know that that's
not what this was this wasn't a business
thing this was like hey have you
listened to this album yeah and so I was
actually thinking about that when you're
a second ago I was like yeah I haven't
gotten back on that text thread to be
like I also don't like the album that
you recommended but I only listened to
it one time and so then he was like oh
you gotta let's do it two or three times
so then I was like okay I'm gonna listen
to this album again and then I'm gonna
get in all the text thread but I could
also just say that on the text threat
but I think it was cool that you know
that and he liked it either
every single time or the vast majority
of time he initiates the the
conversation because we just did like I
don't know if we've ever initiated a
text with Matt but like every month or
so there's like a little exchange and
it's it's a it's that it's actually
valuable for me to like just sit for
what it is and for me not to attach some
sort of guilt that's also valuable
because he's introduced us Matt is the
one who introduced us to Sturgill
and then Jason Isbell I don't think
Sturgill cuz I think we went in Amoeba
Records and I literally saw the record
and I was like who is this okay well I
know for a fact he introduced me to
Jason this bill yeah
and that I am as thankful for that as
any music recommendation that I've ever
gotten oh wow and then you've got Tim
who I think because of result of some of
the stories we told on this podcast that
he started to reach out to discuss those
with us and correct her correct our
errors direct our errors but it led to
like fact just us having more of a
conversation and connecting more and I
really enjoyed that it was like it was a
little odd that's like okay he's
listening to ear biscuits and then he's
and I'll tell you why it was odd I'll
try to articulate that and then because
he's probably listening but it felt odd
to me cuz it was just like okay you you
know he's sitting on a conversation
we're having but we're not having it
with him so it's like I don't know I
guess I have all this guilt associated
with friends because I'm like I feel bad
you're listening to our podcast but you
can't be here at the table to be a part
of the conversation like if we were if
we had an active friendship like we used
to have like you'd have a seat at the
table and I know that's not that's not
healthy and and I don't know he's not
thinking that but I start to think like
if Greg or Tim or Matt listen to our
podcast did they start to feel like
we're not good friends or something to
them because we never initiate
conversations with oh I don't know why I
attach so much guilt to these things but
I do actually
I guess I'll share this story where it
really came to a head a friend out here
in LA and I'm gonna try to be very
careful when telling this story because
it's this story's about me it's not
about him at all but it's about a text
exchange that I had because I was we
he's a he's a friend that like we were
close
play years ago like right when we move
to LA but then it was like because
purely because of circumstantial reasons
we fell out of of being in contact like
it went from seeing each other every
week or every few weeks even if you
didn't plan it we would see each other
and having little conversations that
then kind of trickles into hey let's
make plans or we're going here for lunch
you want to come type of thing too like
none of that we're just in different
circles kind of like what some people
ask how do you reconnect and so then it
would be like once maybe twice a year
we'd see each other or he would come
over and we would have this reconnection
session that would be like an hour or
maybe two hours and it would be great to
reconnect but then it would it would be
like radio silence from both parties for
a long time and I guess one day oh it
caught me at a bad time that he decided
to text me out of the blue and it was
just a it was just a friendly text it
was something like miss you man or
thinking about you and I I've been
struggling with in general and you know
where the story's going but I was I was
struggling with if I feel something or
if I think something I should say it so
in just in general like I'm trying to
become a person who's more honest about
what I'm what I'm thinking or feeling or
going through or response how I feel
like I should respond to somebody and I
thought it would be a healthy practice
for me to respond to his texts with
exactly what I thought what I thought in
the moment and but what I was thinking
was I don't well you know what I'll read
what I wrote back okay I remember this
he's like dude I miss you that was his
text again this is about me not him that
was all his tag set
and I was like I'm just gonna I got a
lot of feelings are coming up in me and
I just and this is what I wrote
hey ma'am thanks for the message
honestly it's very tough for me to know
how to respond so I'll just be real
about it I care about you but I just
don't have time in my life where I'm at
right now right now with family and work
to devote enough time to take the
friendship we had before and make it
work now there are a few friends in my
life now that I'm actively trying to
maintain a quality friendship with and
it is proving to be very difficult
purely from a practical standpoint I
wish it weren't the case but I respect
you and wanted to be honest about it so
I'm writing this from a place of love
thanks for hearing me out man hahaha and
you're laughing because why on earth
would anybody who has an ounce of
kindness in their heart write this in
response to a friend who simply wrote
dude I miss you right is that what
you're laughing at well no I'm laughing
because this is such a it's just such a
linked thing to I it just it's comical
to me now it was an experiment in
honesty because well I felt guilty about
everything that I felt let me true and
let me I'm gonna as your best friend I
want to comment on that because I find
that very interesting that that first of
all I think your instincts are great
right I think that the guilt that you
feel about friendships and your sense of
obligation and yours and your obligation
to be honest with people and these are
all really good things this is not this
is this shows that you're a person of
character I think that it's interesting
that you made a conscious decision to be
like I feel like I need to say what I
think more because
on the spectrum of people who say what
they think you're pretty high on the
spectrum of the frequency with which you
say what you think candor is pretty high
potentially the highest of anyone that I
know personally okay okay if you can
name a person who says what they think
about things more often than you that we
know collectively I would be interested
to know who that person is I can think
of one person that that we knew and I
didn't much like this person for that so
that person would always say exactly
what they thought and so it's it's and
of course with no concern for how it
would be received and so yeah and where
my Tennessee I know that I don't talk a
lot now that I don't have a lot of
opinions but in certain situations like
this it's just like I'm always gonna be
on team just say something to be nice to
just keep things where they're at don't
push away and don't pull that / like my
tendencies to say something that just
kind of keeps things at a stasis that's
just my instinct I'm not saying it's
good or bad but in every type of
interaction
I'm just not I want to move things
further in either direction and that's
just my sort of knee-jerk response to
any kind of interaction like that well
and I just it just drove me crazy to
feel like I I respected this person this
friend of mine that I couldn't I
couldn't give them what I felt like a
true friend would give and it and so
just I felt like I needed to define the
relationship so to speak well and I'm
out of respect but I will say in
addition to this to add more color to
this situation without getting into
specifics that this person was going
through something difficult and had
reached out to both of us and spent some
time kind of catching us up on what they
were going through and it was obvious it
it was obvious that they want
and needed friends to kind of help them
get through this situation and so there
was a you know we had similar
interactions you with him and then me
with him separately I don't think we got
together the three of us know and I felt
like it was weird for me because I was
like I don't think I can give this
person what they need right now
for a number of really complex reasons
but I just and so and maybe you
communicate he didn't send me a text I
said I miss you because I assume that
when you're interacting you felt more of
an obligation to be like okay I can see
what this guy needs and I'm gonna try to
give it to him which that's not that's
not good on me that's good on you I mean
I'm I'm probably giving out the vibe
that's just like okay I can see that red
is not available to me in this way and
so he's not but he may have thought that
you were available to him in that way so
you probably sensed a little bit of
pressure when he sends that text it's
like hey I still need you to help me
through this but and his response was
very gracious very kind but it was also
clarifying that I mean he was basically
saying I was just I was just being
friendly this wasn't coming from a place
of me needing something from you I just
you know I just wanted it was more of
just like a friendly refresh checking it
yeah it was just like and it wasn't it
wasn't anything more than that and there
was a little bit of an exchange data
where we clarified what what each other
meant and then a day later I base I
wrote back one last thing and I I said I
read back through my text and just
wanted to apologize for giving what must
have felt like a cold hearted
out of the blue response to a friendly
kind text I was trying to respect you by
being honest about what I was able to
give even though you were not asking for
anything and I'm sorry if it insulted
her otherwise hurt you you deserve
better and I think that's what I was
actually trying to say
and he responded I appreciate that and
that I mean because of my experiment in
honesty I'll call it air quotes that was
apparently the end of our friendship
it was definitely the end of that
exchange in it I mean I guess that was
that was my message it was like I love
you and respect you but I don't have
time to invest in a friendship in the
way that I think you deserve therefore I
just needed to get this off my chest and
break up with you I like I I I regret it
I think about when am I gonna cross
paths with this guy and you know in a
Ralphs grocery store on the street or
something and like I often think about
what I'm going to say and now I'm
tortured by that you know it's like well
so let's let's get back to her question
though right yeah because I don't I
think maybe we have different
perspectives on this and that's fine
we're you know and I'm not I'm not just
saying this is my advice because this is
what I do because I don't I'd it isn't
that I don't feel guilty about it at all
but when we talk about it in this way
but I think I've made a decision and
maybe this is a decision out of
self-preservation but I mean one of the
things that I have learned in therapy is
that it's okay to make decisions that
have your own health your own mental
well-being in mind and I think that you
know we come from a place where I think
that there is a sense that you know
self-sacrifice is super important and
kind of always putting other people's
needs before yours is super important
and I'd and I I in principle agree with
those things in principle right but
there's some times just because like
sometimes your needs are actually you
you got to think about what your
jeans are and you have to think about
the reality of a situation and so I
think the way that I interact with these
long-term friendships is this like okay
when I have the opportunity like a real
opportunity whether that's a text
exchange even if it's just initiated by
the other person or it's seeing them in
person I want to be present and I want
to be available and I want to be
invested in the friendship for that time
but then when we're not physically
together and we kind of go back to our
own lives because we're not in the
situation that we're going to be brought
into each other's presence on a regular
basis I'm going to be okay with the fact
that there's not much of a friendship in
the gaps and I'm and I'm gonna be okay
with that because I feel like trying to
make anything beyond that happen it's
gonna be something that I'm not going to
be good at it and it's not gonna be a
regular thing and it's only going to
lead to disappointment if we can have an
understanding that there's not gonna be
much here until we see each other again
and hey let's let's be open to that
let's try to make that happen if we're
gonna be in the area I'm gonna let you
know so we can get together like let's
be proactive about planning hey let's go
to see a game back in Raleigh together
or something like that or hate we're
coming to your town come out to our show
and let's hang out I
my advice to these three people who are
asking about different situations it's
like and I don't I don't know if some
some of these situations may not be like
a long distance it was it may just be
like I was friends with this person and
now I'm not my tendency is just to be
like friendships are very difficult but
I don't I don't know if it depends on
the situation but I don't know if it's
worth it to be like alright I'm going to
place the burden on myself that if I
don't if this friendship is not
rekindled there's something wrong with
me or the you know what I'm saying like
I don't think yeah I don't think you
have to force it yeah I do think I I
appreciate what you're saying it's
helpful because I think
friendships are that their it it's a
it's a reciprocating cyclical process
you know it's a it's a relationship and
there's give and there's take and take
and give and it it takes both parties
being on enough of the same page to
continue to move a friendship forward so
if you're wanting to if you're the one
wanting to rekindle the friendship you
got to respect the fact that some that
person on the other end of that might
not be in a position to make that happen
or exactly the way that you would want
it to or envision it it coming together
if at all I found in the in the
clarifying exchange that I have with
with my friend and I do
I do still call him a friend he
clarified that he knew but based on the
fact that he like whenever conversation
happened it would be hit on his
initiative say he said I actually
understand that and you know so me
reaching out was just a kindness you
know it wasn't there were no or no
strings attached I think that's why I
feel bad is that like I made assumptions
where there
I mean wrong assumptions about why he
was saying and that like there were
strings attached that they weren't which
then it was that was presumptuous where
he was just being nice
you know yeah but I think I mean
relationships are dicey and you in so
you've got to be you and you can't like
I said you can't force you can't force
something to work if it's not gonna work
and that doesn't mean you shouldn't try
but you should you should I think your
advice is an initiate lightly and just
see what comes of it I mean it's just
like in a romantic relationship if
you're really into somebody you can't
you can't you can lead a horse to water
so to speak you can't make somebody fall
in love with you but don't date a horse
especially if they're a horse don't date
a horse
it's I mean it's it's much more its I we
don't I think we fall back on thinking
of friendships as being this thing
that's like oh it's so easy and it just
happens and it's like I'm aren't I
likable aren't you likeable well then
what can't we be friends it's like
there's a lot of freaking factors it's
very I mean it's in many ways it's just
as challenging as a romantic
relationship and we you know I think
that we may be thinking about this in a
very narrow way because of our age
mm-hmm
because we just assumed again we've
already established that we're not great
at connecting with people
digitally mm-hmm your phone or text or
heck I've got a VR headset now I could
sit down in a room with someone who's
got one and maybe physical proximity
will continue to become less and less a
factor in maintaining a friendship and
maybe that has already happened and
because I think what I just said a
second ago is that hey listen if you're
good if if we're together physically I
want to make an effort to be there for
you and to be a listening ear and to
catch up and to be present but if we're
not physically present together the best
I'm going to do is just try to be
proactive about opportunities for us to
be physically present together that are
practical and maybe that's a really
narrow way to look at it I understand
that about myself and you might be like
hey guys listen my best friends are
people that are in different countries
that I connect with that I video chat
with what what is this right most of the
people that we're talking about are
kinda like us of our generation and not
video chatting with a lot of people in
the way that like our kids will just you
know you were talking about Lincoln just
being on like a constant video chat with
a group of friends yeah
on that like house party app or whatever
it was yeah
and I understand okay this generation
next generation is different so maybe
our advice is not very applicable to
them so I don't know where you're at
with these situations I would just say
that if you feel like you you need that
person like you
need that friendship or they might need
that friendship then I think like you
said sort of initiating but not
initiating what don't I just the idea of
putting a burden on yourself and filling
this all of a sudden there's a negative
obligation or guilt that's associated
with your interaction with that person
to me I just don't like that negativity
when I want to think when I think about
somebody we went to college with I've
got good memories and I think about the
next time we're hanging out we're gonna
have a good time but I don't want to
think about and then every other time I
think about them all I do is just
associate guilt with the fact that I
don't talk to them enough yeah this
doesn't seem healthy it's not so how can
I focus on what the positive is but you
like you said if they're going through
something they need somebody to talk to
they need somebody to show up for them
whether that's physically or digitally
then I hope that I can do that you know
feel an obligation to do that but that
doesn't mean in every sense it's
appropriate or the right choice for you
to even do that right I think we do need
to say that it's like just because
somebody needs a friend there there has
to be scenarios where that the automatic
I mean you have to be that friend right
so I'm just trying to tip the scales and
I'm saying that more for myself and
again that that wasn't actually the case
I think I might have brought some of
that assumption but that wasn't the case
with it with this scenario that I
explored but I actually don't know where
you is it where do you come down on this
text exchange that I mean if you're
saying you would have just been nice and
like you would have continued the
niceties and then I mean and then the
opposite that's one extreme right is it
not because and the other extreme is
clearly what I did which is basically
break off the friendship because I
couldn't be you know the everything I
thought I had to be which wasn't even
the case I don't know I mean I
definitely am
like I said I'm my tendency is to
maintain the status quo and I don't I
really don't like uncomfortable
situations I don't like awkwardness I
don't like conflict and so it's really
difficult for me when I'm not like okay
I need to be honest with this person so
that we can clarify where we're at so we
can actually reach some sort of
conclusion like I'm much more likely to
be like okay this is going to be this
sort of thing that just indefinitely
continues and isn't really that big of
an inconvenience it's easy to just send
back a text that says miss you two men
but when it's like hey let's get
together and do this and it's like I've
got I've got these people that I that I
feel like I need to prioritize because
they're like in more in my inner circle
and I can't say yes to to them right now
and give them what they what I want to
give them forget what they need what I
want to give them as a friend then then
at that point you got it Emma you're
just line saying actually I can't get
together I have plans you know it's like
you're just letting people read between
the lines it's like okay you can see
that you're initiating you know I'm not
a I'm not a bad person for just a you
know I think most people can get the
message it's like hey yeah it's not that
I don't like you it's just that I don't
have capacity I think my theory is that
you arrive at the same result
yeah with a little less awkwardness yeah
and it might take a little bit longer to
get there for somebody to get the
message oh he's not really available I'm
not I don't necessarily think that one
is better or worse I you were ripping
the band-aid off I'm letting the
band-aid fall off in the shower you know
what I'm saying and maybe it should have
come I wouldn't shower with someone
who's not that close of a friend but go
ahead
may-maybe the band-aid should have come
off a little bit earlier but I tend to
it really takes a lot for me to have an
uncomfortable conversation with somebody
so well IIIi tend for me to take this to
therapy clearly yes I mean I think
there's probably some deep-rooted aband
fear of abandonment
thing that then I don't want to put on
other people even then when that when
they're not even expecting or fearing
that themselves I would say that that
would be something I think it's probably
something in that arena so I mean we can
leave it at that I'm not it seems we I'm
pressing you to solve my my problem I
don't have a solution I'm just telling
you the way that I would do it and it it
tends to be okay yeah I've definitely
slowed my role on unsane what I'm
thinking which brings it back to this
still may be obnoxious at times level
that you used to I don't know how much
help we've been we didn't answer a lot
of questions we did answer three
questions in wonder what it was help
took a lot I mean it was it was it was
helpful for me thank you we did what we
often do which is we take your questions
and then we make it you now you're
apologizing for that an internal
exploration of our own lives but
hopefully that we're you know what we're
all learning together as a large
community and hopefully we're getting
better at doing things friendships as we
go I quite enjoyed the conversation and
I'm kind of nervous about it going out
there but and if you do you will I do
have a wreck in effect okay mine is a
book that I am listening to that
everybody's talking about this block oh
you got it you you gotta read it or
listen to it I'm half way through it
it's captivating us enthralling is catch
and kill by Ronan Farrow
so of course Ronan Farrow he is most
known as being Woody Allen and Mia
Farrow's son even though he for
understandable reasons likes to distance
himself from his famous parents and he
has a career of his own as a journalist
and he will help you just gave him he
was the one who was very instrumental in
sort of breaking the Harvey Weinstein's
story ah and it's just this incredibly
engrossing tale of him trying to get to
the bottom of the story and just be able
to report it
and all the crazy stuff that he
encountered in the process of going
after someone as big and as powerful and
as with many as many connections as
Harvey Weinstein just fascinating
fascinating story unless a docu is the
docq novel yeah and his the audiobook
which he was actually if some people
made fun of him for this but I thought
it was great
oh okay he does he does all the voices
for his audiobook and he like does like
impersonations of the people that he
spoke with whether they be Australian
British or you know a woman with a
sultry voice and he basically just does
all the accents and he's he does a
really good job at it but it's not but
it's nonfiction it's not fiction this is
all any plays work like there's a
recording there's the famous recording
of Harvey Weinstein that one of the
actresses that he was harassing took Wow
and it's in there anyway
fascinating story if you're into that
kind of thing
catch and kill I'm recommending the
audiobook because that's what I've
listened to but I'm sure it's a great
book to read as well okay thanks for
hanging out with us hashtag Oh every
time I say hashtag now I want to say
hashtag bleak Creek because well you
know what promoting the novel so much
talking about nice ear biscuits you can
use both of them if you want to talk
about hashtag bleak creek on hashtag ear
biscuits we don't care how many hashtag
hash tags you use but you know what you
can hashtag count on us hash tag being
back again next week just like we are
most every week and can and you know
what be in your friend yeah you know
what will be your friend
hashtag friends we're your friends to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]